can I find out where I left my wallet by
drinking a cooler full of beer hi I'm
Tim and this is science the show we're a
rogue scientist me uses his big dumb
brain to figure out real world problems
this week's problem hits close to home
I'll attempt to harness the power yeast
to find out where I left my wallet this
isn't just an experiment it's also
serious because seriously I can't
remember what I did with my wallet I
don't even know what it looks like a new
study in the British Medical Journal
revealed that people who drink heavily
are more likely to develop dementia
which is sort of like saying Nazis
happened to be heavily racist but here's
where the study gets interesting they
found that people who don't drink at all
may also be more likely to get dementia
which explains why my Mormon landlord
always calls me Kevin even though my
name is obviously where do I fit into
this well I haven't had a drink in 15
years after that crazy boating accident
others oh wait is it a boat or a horse
that's besides the point
my hypothesis if people who drink
heavily if people who drink more heavily
or sorry heavily or not at all
heavily or not at all are more likely to
eventually deal with severe brayton more
likely to avoid or mmmm if people who
drink heavily or not at all are more
likely to eventually deal with memory
loss than perhaps drinking just the
right amount of puke fuel will help me
find my goddamn wallet
so I'm about to find out in an
experiment I like to call booze cruise
down memory lane I've organized these
cans of generic IPA in three separate
categories happy drunk slurring my words
but it's totally fine drunk and drunker
if my calculations are correct I should
start remembering where my wallet is
before I reached run Kirk focus on the
wallet
it's made of pleather a $20 in monopoly
money in it that's all I got
well then hold on I think I'm getting
something here I just remembered the
lyrics from city highs what would you
know what would you know if your son was
at home crying all alone on the bathroom
floor cause he's hungry and the only way
to feed him is to sleep with a man for a
little bit of money and his daddy's gone
somewhere smoking rock down in and out
of lockdown I ain't got a job now
so did me this is what you call
something life I remember where I left
my wallet I left him in my shorts
thanks alcohol so what did we learn
today we learned a moderate amount of
beer does help keep your memory intact
but the most important lesson I've
learned is that wallets are just like
memories even if you lose a couple you
can always make new ones for example my
co-workers will never forget the time I
didn't wear pants for a whole day
HR won't either if I don't get fired
I'll see you next time on science
[Music]